ma tante
je m'appelle Maya Rama Sami j'ai 41 ans
deux enfants et il y a un peu plus de
deux ans chez voulu me réorienter en
fait professionnellement j'étais dans la
communication avant j'ai
effectué une formation cuisine pour
ouvrir un restaurant donc qui est
maintenant ouvert depuis un peu plus
d'un an enfin mai l'année dernière
c'est vraiment une voix que j'ai choisie
j'ai jamais eu de regret d'avoir changé
de métier et d'avoir entamé cette
aventure là
j'apprends beaucoup du coup c'est la
première fois que je gère une entreprise
donc c'est vraiment un apprentissage
quotidien et c'est ça qui me plaît en
fait dans
le travail il y a une petite partie vie
de famille le matin avec les enfants à
déposer à l'école
petit déjeuner rapide ou pas de petit
déjeuner quand il y a pas le temps et
puis donc là il est 8 heures et quart on
va pas tarder à y aller
pense pas que l'objectif de son
restaurant c'est simplement pécunier du
style je vais gagner de l'argent c'est
vraiment ce plaisir de donner quelque
chose
de bon et de satisfaire des personnes
que ce soit pas que des amis ou vraiment
c'est tout le monde ce qui me plaît le
plus c'est le contact avec les clients
c'est vrai que c'est un des aspects
importants quand même dans le dans le
milieu d'être commercial l'échange avec
les gens et c'est vrai qu'au bout d'un
an on a quand même pas mal de clients
fidèles maintenant qu'on connaît qui
viennent régulièrement donc cet aspect
là le côté humain de du boulot est quand
même assez sympa
ce qui est mis en avant au comptoir du
potager donc c'est de manger sain avec
des produits locaux des légumes beaucoup
de légumes du poisson c'est aussi de pas
jeter les barquettes en plastique donc
de les ramener pour qu'elle soit
recyclée plutôt positif les clients sont
contents il y en a un très très bon
retour par le bouche à oreille donc tout
ce que j'espère que c'est que ça
poursuivre sur cette voilà qu'on puisse
continuer à développer le restaurant et
à satisfaire les clients qu'on a déjà et
les nouveaux clients éventuellement